I think that the arguments that once we
have super intelligent computers and
robots they will inevitably want to take
over and do away with us comes from
Prometheus and Pandora myths it's based
on confusing the idea of high
intelligence with megalomaniacal goals
now we I think it's a projection of
alpha male psychology onto the very
concept of intelligence intelligence is
the ability to solve problems to achieve
goals under uncertainty it doesn't tell
you what those goals are and there's no
reason to think that just the
concentrated analytic ability to solve
goals is going to mean that one of those
goals is going to be to subjugate
humanity or to achieve unlimited power
it just so happens that the intelligence
that we're most familiar with namely
ours is a product of the Darwinian
process of natural selection which is an
inherently competitive process which
means that a lot of the organisms that
are highly intelligent also have a
craving for power and an ability to be
utterly callous to those who stand in
their way if we create intelligence
that's intelligent design I mean our
intelligent design creating something
and unless we program it with the goal
of subjugating less intelligent beings
there's no reason to think that it will
naturally evolve in that direction
particularly if like with every gadget
that we invent we build in safeguards I
mean we have cars we also put in airbags
we also put in bumpers as we develop
smarter and smarter artificially
intelligent systems if there's some
danger that it will through some
oversight shoot off in some direction
that starts to work against our
interests then that that's a safeguard
that that we could build in and we know
by the way that it's possible to have
high intelligence without megalomaniacal
or homicidal or genocidal tendencies
because there we do know that there is a
highly advanced form of intelligence
that tends not to have
I desire and they're called women I
think it may not be a coincidence that
the people who think well you make
something smart it's gonna want to
dominate all belong to a particular
gender